right five and one-fourth as an improper
fraction so just as a reminder an
improper fraction is one where the
numerator is greater than or equal to
the denominator so improper fraction
means that the numerator and actually I
should say the absolute value of the
numerator is greater than or equal to
the absolute value of the denominator
nominator I could have just shortened it
but that you get the idea the numerator
is greater than or equal to the absolute
or the absolute value of the numerator
is greater than or equal to the absolute
value of the denominator in this citchen
situation right here it's a mixed number
we have it as a combination of five
which is just a whole number and
one-fourth which is a proper fraction
because the numerator is less than the
denominator the absolute value of the
numerator is less than the absolute
value of the denominator so to write it
as an improper fraction and I'll show
you kind of the methodology for do it
and then we'll for doing it and then
we'll talk a little bit about why that
methodology works so 5 and 1/4 the
methodology is pretty straightforward
you say ok 5 the whole number 5 that is
the same thing as 20 over 4 and so 20
over 4 plus 1 over 4 is 21 over 4 or
another way to think about it is 5 times
4 is 20 plus 1 is 21 21 over 4 so that's
the methodology pretty straightforward
and I want to I'm going to draw it out
so it makes a little bit more sense so
once again you take the mixed number or
you take the whole part of the mixed
number you multiply it times the
denominator you get 20 and then you add
that 20 to 1 you get 21 over 4 and now
it's an improper fraction the absolute
value of our numerator is greater than
the absolute value of our denominator
now I do want to show you why this works
so to see why this works let's think
about what 5 and 1/4 it's means it means
we have 5 holes so let's say that this
is a hole so that's one hole and let me
copy and paste it 5 times
so copy then let me paste it let me
paste it so that's 2 that's 3
that's four and then that is five so we
have five holes so that's that's this
stuff that I've drawn in green so let me
make it that's five holes right there
and then we have one-fourth and then we
have then we have one-fourth so I'll do
1/4 of a hole so 1/4 of a hole will look
like that and just to be clear that it's
part of a whole I could have drawn the
hole I'll draw the hole in a dotted line
to say that we don't have that hole we
have only 1/4 of it and that's that one
for it so this is 5 and 1/4 it's so to
write it as an improper fraction you can
really view this 5 as some fraction over
4 and to think of it that way
divide each of these into fourths or
this is one way to think about it so
this is this right over here is 4/4 this
is another 4/4 this is another 4/4 I
should have copied and pasted this this
is another 4/4 and this is another 4/4
so now how many fourths do we have how
many fourths we have 4/4 here 4/4 here
four fourths here four fourths here and
four fourths here so just what we have
in green just in what we have in green
we have twenty-fourths we have 24 it's
that's what we have in green right over
here that is the same thing as five each
of these are 4/4 so this is you could
view this as five you could view this as
five times four fourths right 4/4 is 1/5
times 4/4 is 20 over four that's what we
have right over here and then you now we
can add it to that 1/4 now you can add
it to that 1/4 and you will get 21 we
have the same denominator so we can just
add the numerators 21 over 4 so that's
the conceptual understanding of why it
works but when you see any mixed number
it's a pretty straightforward process
multiply the 5 times 4 you get 20 20
plus 1 is equal to 21 over 4 and
actually let me just write that out just
so you get clear on what I'm doing so 5
and 1/4 it's that is the same thing as
that's equal to 5 times 4 plus 1
over
or and this is why